in this video we're going to look at
pairs of molecules and see if they
relate to each other and any in any
obvious way or maybe less than obvious
way so these first two right here they
actually look like completely different
molecules so your gut impulse maybe you
see these these are completely different
molecules and it wouldn't be completely
off but if we look a little bit closer
you see that this guy on the Left has
one two three four carbons and so does
this guy on the right has one two three
four carbons this guy on the left has
two four six seven eight hydrogen's this
guy on the right has two four six eight
hydrogen's and they both have one oxygen
so both of the molecular formulas for
both of these things are four carbons
eight hydrogen's and one oxygen they're
both c4h8 oh so they have the same
molecular formula made up of the same
thing so these are going to be isomers
they're going to be isomers and there
are special type of isomers in this
situation we don't have the same bonds
we're made up of the same things but the
bonds what is connected to what is
different so we call this a
constitutional isomer constitutional
constitutional isomer so we are
essentially made up of the same things
but we are actually two different
molecules actually two very different
molecules here now let's look at this
first guy or this next guy over here so
if we look at this molecule let's see
does look like this carbon is chiral it
is an asymmetric carbon it is bonded to
four different groups for een bromine
hydrogen and then a methyl group and
so's this one and they've both made up
of the same things you have the carbon
and not only are they made up of the
same things but the bonding is the same
so carbon 2 14 carbon 2 a fluorine
carbon 2 a bromine carbon 2 bromine
carbon to hydrogen in both and then
carbon 2 the methyl group and both but
they don't look quite the same are they
mirror images well no this guy's mirror
image would have the fluorine popping
out here the hydrogen going back here
and then we
have the bromine pointing out here let's
see if I can somehow get from this guy
to that guy let me let me flip this guy
first so let me a good thing to do would
be - would be to just flip see the
fastest way I could potentially
potentially get there well let me just
flip it like this so I'm going to flip
out of the page you can imagine I'm
going to flip it like this so I'm going
to take this methyl group and then put
it on the right-hand side and you could
imagine i'm going to turn it so it would
come out of the page and then go back
down so if i did that what would it look
like i would have the carbon this carbon
here i would have the methyl group on
that side now and then since i flipped
it over the bromine was in the plane of
the page it'll still be in the plane of
the page but since i flipped it over the
hydrogen which was now it which was in
the back will now be in the front the
hydrogen will now be in the front and
the fluorine will now in the back
because i flipped it over so the
fluorine is now in the back now how does
this compare to that let's see if i can
somehow get there well if I take this
fluorine and I rotate it to where the
hydrogen is and I take the hydrogen and
rotate it to where that's all going to
happen at once to where the bromine is
and I take the bromine rotate to where
the fluorine is I get that so I can flip
it and then I can rotate it around this
I guess this bond axis right there and I
would get to that molecule there so even
though they look pretty different with a
flip and a rotation you actually see
that these are the same molecule same
same molecule next one so let's see what
do we have here let me switch colors so
over here this part of both of these
molecules look the same you have the
carbons on both of them this carbon
looks like a chiral Center it's bonded
to one two three different groups these
are you might say oh it's two carbons
but this is a methyl group and then this
side has all this business over it so
this is definitely a chiral carbon and
over here same thing
it's a chiral carbon and this has the
same thing it's bonded to four different
things
so each of these molecules have two
carbons and it looks like they have
they're made up of the same things and
not only are they made up of the same
things but they the bond the bonds are
made in the same way so this carbon is
bonded to a hydrogen and a fluorine and
then two other carbons same thing
hydrogen and a fluorine carbon it looks
like it's a hydrogen it's bonded to a
car hydrogen and a chlorine so all of
it's made up of the same constituents
and they're bonded in the same way so
these look like these look like but the
bonding is a little bit different over
here on this one on the left the
hydrogen goes in the back and over here
the hydrogen to the front and over here
the chlorines and back and over here the
chlorines in front so these look like
stereo isomers stereo isomers you saw
earlier in this video you saw structural
isomers made up of the same things but
the connections are all different
stereoisomers they're made up of the
same thing the connections are the same
but the three-dimensional configuration
is a little bit different for example
here on this carbon it's connected to
the same things as this carbon but over
here the fluorines out front and over
here out here the fluorine is out front
over here the fluorines backwards and
same thing for the chlorine here it's
back here and its front here now let's
see if they're related in it I guess in
a more nuanced way well if you put a you
could imagine putting a mirror behind if
you put a desolated visual imagine
putting a mirror behind this molecule if
you put a mirror behind this molecule
what would its reflection look like so
if you put a mirror behind it in the
image of the mirror this hydrogen would
now since the mirror is behind this
whole molecule this hydrogen is actually
closer to the mirror so then the mirror
image you would have a hydrogen that's
pointed out and then you would have the
carbon and then you would have the
fluorine being further away and same
thing in the mirror image here you would
have the chlorine coming closer since
this chlorine is further back closer to
the mirror and then you would have the
hydrogen pointing outwards like that and
then obviously the rest of the molecule
would look would look exactly would look
exactly the same and so this mirror
image that I just thought about
in white is exactly what this molecule
is hydrogen pointing out in front
hydrogen pointing out in front Chloe you
know you might say wait this hydrogen is
on the on the right this one's on the
left it doesn't matter this is actually
saying that the hydrogen's pointing out
front fluorine is pointing out back
hydrogen up front fluorine back chlorine
out front hydrogen back chlorine out
front hydrogen back so these are
actually mirror images but they're not
the easy mirror images that we've done
in the past where the mirror was just
like that in between the two these are
this one is a mirror image where you
place the mirror either on top of or
behind one of the molecules so this is a
class of stereoisomers and we've brought
up this word before we call this
enantiomers enantiomer so each of these
are an enantiomer I'll say they're
enantiomers of each other they're stereo
isomers they're made up of the same
molecules so that they have the same
constituents they also have the same
connections and not only do they have
the same connections that that so far
gets a sister isomer but they're a
special kind of stereo isomer called an
enantiomer where they are actual mirror
images of each other now what is this
one over here in blue just like the last
one looks like it's made up of the same
things you have these carbons these
carbons these carbons and hydrogen's up
there same thing over there you have a
hydrogen bromine hydrogen and a bromine
hydrogen and chlorine hydrogen chlorine
hydrogen chlorine hydrogen chlorine so
it's made up of the same things they're
connected in the same way so they're
definitely stereo isomers well we have
to make sure they're not that well let's
make sure they're not the same molecule
first here hydrogen's in the front there
hydrogen's in the back here hydrogen is
in the back here hydrogen in the front
so they're not the same molecule they
have a three a different
three-dimensional configuration although
their bond the the bond connections are
the same so these are stereo isomers
these are stereo I stereo isomers well
let's see if there are nan chalmers so
if we look at it like this you put a
mirror here you wouldn't get this guy
over here then you would have a chlorine
out front and a hydrogen so you won't
get it if you get a mirror
there but if we do the same exercise
that we did in the last in the last pair
if you put a mirror behind this guy if
you put a mirror behind this guy and I'm
just going to focus on stuff that's just
forward and back because that's that's
what's relevant if the mirror is sitting
behind the molecule so the mayor is
sitting behind the molecule this
hydrogen or this bromine is actually
closer to the mirror then that hydrogen
so the bromine will now be out front and
then the hydrogen will be in back this
hydrogen will be in the back I'm trying
to if you're trying to do a kind of a
mirror image if it's hard to
conceptualize and then that would all
look the same and then this chlorine
will now be out front and this hydrogen
will now be in the back in our mirror
image if we can visualize it and then we
have another one and then this chlorine
is closer to the mirror that's kind of
it's sitting on top of so in the mirror
image it would be pointing out and then
this hydrogen would be pointing back now
let's see our is our mirror image the
same as this so in the mirror image our
bromine is pointing in the front
hydrogen in the back there then we have
hydrogen and in then in our mirror image
we have the hydrogen back chlorine in
front same there so so far it's looking
like a mirror image and then in the this
last carbon over here chlorine in front
hydrogen and back but here we have
chlorine in the back hydrogen in front
so this this part you can think of it
this way this is the mirror image of
this this is the mirror image of this
part but this is not the mirror image of
that part so when you have a when you
have a stereoisomer that is not a mirror
when you have two stereoisomers that
aren't mirror images of each other we
call them diastereomers I always have
trouble saying that let me write it it
these are these are diastereomer
diastereomers which is essentially
saying it's a stereo isomer that is not
an enantiomer that's all it means stereo
isomer not in answer Maria steer isomer
it's either going to be an enantiomer or
a diastereomer
now let's do this last one let's see we
have to site we have this we have this
kind of cyclo hexane ring and they have
a bromo on on I guess the number one and
the number two group depending how you
think about it
looks like they are mirror images of
each other we could put a mirror right
there and there definitely they look
like mirror images and this is a chiral
carbon here it's bonded to one carbon
group that is different than this carbon
group this carbon group has a bromine
this carbon group doesn't have just has
a bunch of hydrogen's on it if you kind
of go in that direction so and it is
hydrogen and then a bromine so that is
chiral and then same argument that is
also chiral and obviously this one is
chiral and that is chiral but if you
think about it they are mirror images of
each other and they do have two they
each have two chiral centers or two
chiral carbons but if you think about it
all you have to do is flip this guy over
and you will get this molecule these are
the same molecules so it is the same
molecule so this is interesting and we
saw this when we first learned about
chirality even though we have two chiral
centers this is not a chiral molecule it
is the same thing as its mirror image it
is superimposable on its mirror image it
is it is super imposable imposable
on its mirror image mirror image so even
though it has chiral carbons in it it is
not a chiral molecule and we call these
meso compounds meso compound this is a
and we could point to one of them
because they really are the same
compound this is a mezzo mezzo compound
it has chiral centers it has chiral
carbons I guess you could say but it is
not a chiral compound and the way to
spot these fairly straightforward is
that you have chiral centers but there
is a line of symmetry here there is a
line of symmetry right here these two
and these two sides of the compound are
mirror images of each other now this
these would not be the same molecule if
this was if I change that to a fluorine
and I changed that to a fluorine then
all of a sudden you do not have this
symmetry these are mirror images but
they would not be superimposable so that
was a fluorine these would actually be
enantiomers and this would not be only
one meso compound
it would be two different enantiomers
and one of them would probably would
have a would have a our direction and
one of them would have an S direction if
we go with the with the naming
conventions that we learned in the last
few videos